they come ready to play against one another and
should be a fun Friday night here in Dallas dumped
in circles the Zone kept in at the point and then
flung wide rope hint giving Chase hamonic scored
he sent one through there was traffic in front
of Aer it's the first shot on goal in the game
it's 116 in and the Senators open the scoring
had eyes it little galvanized rubber around the
boards they keep it in the Stars think they're
in good stad of might have even clicked off of
endal in front hamex a light scoring defenseman
late in his career did it went off the inep of
endow and down pass Zack mckuin checks in
Ro charier who was the man who is pegged to
come out of the lineup will stay in they're
not really a four-line team very often that
Circle a shot bson gets it back and he scores his
first shot was blocked Drake bson followed up and
the sends have landed an early onew punch here
in Dallas plays and goals where there's a shot
block first and then the followup first it's
Joel Hanley with the block and bson who's an
eager opportunity scorer grabs this changes the
point of attack a little bit and fairly quickly
onto his forehand and then rips it low past a
stun Jake a Andrew is trying to appear around
his defenseman again I think flip for hinan
piece of the pass Puck goes to the trapezoid
Works free here's hinan settles Robertson
goes low hints in front shot score pelski
they work the puck down low the power play
Cashes in again it's Joe pel's seventh power
play goal of the year I don't understand
this penalty killing essentially all four
penalty killers in front of their net minder
just went after the puck they all they all
just gravitated to where the puck was it left
both Jamie Ben and pavelski alone in front of
the net that's what they do in like Adam where
where they're just so myopically focused on the
puck they just Chase it and disregard for the
responsibilities Around the Net a sweet feed by
hints well four years ago it was the only time
it didn't all even up and nobody wants to sign
up for that again here's Ottawa through Center
ice up ahead giru right Circle held on wedgew
made the save and the rebound scored it was
Norris who got to it Jus set it up with the
move and shot and the s are back in front by a
pair Scott Wedgewood makes a fantastic save on
the original it was Norris that started things
he sprung giru down the right side how nobody
in a green jersey picked up the Senators forward
as he just had an unfettered path to the net he
just walks in there and chunks it home in between
both mro hinan and everybody else four on four
can be weird and it was and costly Norris getss
his eighth goal of this season severely limited
last year because of a shoulder injury shot score
Lindell he gets it right back it's just all goals
and penalties and everything early in American
Airline [Music] Center how perfectly painted
that shot was as it clicked in off the pipe
a little button hook twice by duchan up top
opened up some space forsberg the reaction
on him he understands he should make that
save it's just a shot from the flank glove hand
side around bson bin lost to stick he's able to
get it back but stla charges in spin around shot
off the stick and wide kachuck beaing right back
to sta rer save made kept alive bson he'll score
he got his own second effort very similar to how
he scored the goal back in the first following
up his own play back up by two yeah it it just
breaks down into one-on ones and whether you can
win your battle and you know big kid chock works
it up top B's waiting on it first waiting on
it again and Ryan Suter cannot eliminate him
off the side of the net and shades of the the
goal that noris scored back in the first period
where he was able to you know forage and kind
of hockey hyena it one stab at it two stabs at
it and it is such a good weapon to have when
he can kill off penalties with the frequency
that Dallas does here short-handed Harley rushes
in shot score he got it shorthanded on his own
rebound it's Dallas's seventh shorty as a team
it's the first in the career of Thomas Harley
plus one down to man he had stalled for a couple
of games everyone was a go just takes this around
to the backand from uh I'm going to say it's a
severe angle it's not an impossible angle and
it's the followup if the goenda forsberg doesn't
move Harley can't chop it home but he just nudges
him his knees enough to open some space Harley
never gives up on it Up Down by Kelly he turn in
left Circle and just miss AER at the far post
Dallas could have numbers they'll catch up du
Shane with San duan's in his shot off of the
iron and out and bounced back wide of the neet
amic's able to get it out to [Applause] Center
collected by hinan off of Robertson trapped by
hamik and then turned over it's hint left Circle
his shot saved by forsberg and what an opportunity
there into the Zone void's contact but Senators
got back played up ahead two-on one here for
Ottawa kachuck his shot blocker save by Wedgewood
can't allow the Ottawa Senators to have easy Rush
chances here's johnon curling right Circle
following hin in he scores [Music] henin's
third goal in the last two games this one ties
it at [Music] four well this is some dangling
by the kid and some aggressive Puck Pursuit by
the line it's an axad dangle though essentially
that sets up Meo hinan who just sort of
creeps in it slips through baffs right to
the forehand and a quick slick wrist [Music]
shot that's perfectly placed short side over
the block offensive zone face off controlled
by Dallas du Shane pressured Jed Chan gets it
back Duane walking in back in in front score
and redirected in and Dallas has their first
lead
once the Stars won the draw went to work duain
who's just been a puck hog at times in the game
little give go with Mason Marchman he tries to
go fancy boy ran out of options and real estate
and his backhand flip to the front of the net
goes off the stick blade of Norris the forward
coming back to try to help out capitulation is on
the menu now from the senator side and the stars
have a immediately add pressure in foxa got it
to giru slid across Chan finds on the left wing
side Chen gets it back a shot save the equipment
with Brady kachak RA in front and in front of him
Senators will try a prayer Wedgewood gloves it and
this game is over the Stars fight all the way back